[Music]
boom
craigslist you ever bought anything from
craigslist you can buy pewdiepie's 50
million plaque award we did it
[Laughter]
there's a lot of weird stuff you can buy
and so we will investigate some of the
strangest things
today a bargain if you ask me a door ram
yes i have a door and that was left in
my house this afternoon by the atlantic
county swat team
trying to make 40 bucks off it to help
replace my door
yes that's so good i'll take a [ __ ]
door ram what do i need it for i don't
know
wrapping doors don't stop asking is that
legal i don't think so but it's epic
anyway
electric cut off decoy it's a fake wasp
net
if anyone has a shut off notice i make
and sell these decoys
that's pretty smart i'll buy that off
ebay or
craigslist no wait what is this the best
one-liner
i farted in kroger yesterday no you
farted in kroger yesterday
you were the tall brunette with the near
perfect body that farted in the bread
section last night
i was the tall guy next to you that
looked over and asked was that you
you quickly replied no it wasn't me
you almost seemed insulted i would ask
as
the stink grew you continuance continued
to deny your flatulence
but it was evident i tried to get rid of
the sench by waving two loves
but i'm right you proceed to storm up in
an angry manner
you're beautiful and even if you're a
liar and fart like
clydesdale i'd love to meet up
someone give this man some cooch that's
respect
now i guess that's one way to pick up a
a woman how did you meet your mama
wait your mama i mean my my ah uh a
smart investment if you ask me
red bucket comes in handy during holiday
season christmas is over
so i no longer need it turn this 100
investment into an almost unlimited
amount of money during the holidays
oh my god salvation army again i'm
pretty sure it's not legal
it's an investment a hundred dollar
investment
uh to go to jail basically
what the hell is wrong with craigslist
what the hell is wrong with princess
selling my pet lobster do not under any
circumstances play him johnny cash
i gotta play the lobster johnny cash
right now
i hurt myself
today selling my lobster
goose i love him dearly however
it is time he found the new friend great
with kids
dimitri ma when was this seven months
ago [ __ ]
i i would love to buy dimitri i mean
goose
from dimitri he gets fussy when he isn't
taken for a walk
he hates any music by johnny cash if you
play it he will destroy
anything around i am so confused that
dog is scared that's a scare dog
what an absolute chad lobster i didn't
know you could have lobsters as pet can
you have lobster says
yeah it's a thing a lobster pet is a
thing oh my god a youtuber already did
it
oh my god it's free now chase
oh my god
no no no no no yo i'm all for fun and
gains but dude
you're crossing the line now that thing
is huge dude
don't do that
i feel bad yeah i feel bad for the
lobster
that's not that's not nice don't don't
get a lobster pet
that changed my mind ah here's the
classic
i've seen this so many times this guy
says do you want to boost your funeral
hire me the professional mourner
to come and cry at the funeral below are
the summers
somewhere special wow normal crying
now because she's feeding my dude
bahamian hollering
hundred dollar my dude crying and
rolling on the ground
150 crying and threatening to jump into
the grave
200 crying and actually jumping in the
grave
you know this is real that's amazing
what a time to be alive
this seems like a movie this is ah
crackhead tiffany sells a paperclip
bookmark
and they also sell a 18k gold paperclip
now why in the would you buy that for a
thousand
five hundred what the normal 165 that's
even more offensive
tiffany tiff tiffany stop benny we need
to shoot tiffany hey tiffany this you
is you god damn why does this annoy me
so much
yo no yankee with no brim though
yankee with no brim yo what
bring me no yankee though no yankee no
bread
i have the no yankee no brim i'm
actually rocking it right now guys
only sent me back 29 bucks but man he's
good
uh this guy will beat up your stepdad
for free that's a good price
it's uh you can either get tuber
simulator
or you can have someone beat up your
stepdad they're both free
you make your choice
someone got a march 10 milk and they're
selling it as a limited edition mario
milk
for uh 50 bucks no thanks thank you but
no thanks i'll have the luigi milk
beat me up to impress your
girl i love this i mean i it's not
that's a homie
come on tiffany does the woman in your
life think you're a little [ __ ]
prove her wrong by punching me in the
face i'll come by wherever you are and
hit on her
uh that's when you give me the old marty
mcfly
and lay me out in front of her half up
front
other half do after we cause an
inevitable scene
you know what would be [ __ ] funny if
this guy just takes half
and when once a guy the boyfriend yanks
one at him
he he defends himself and beats the [ __ ]
get out of him and then steals the girl
and gets the other half now that's judge
all right so for a grand you get one
room
in east village my apartment is being
renovated
i have one room for rent i prefer a
female
uh it's just uh him and his son living
there and you have to be very quiet
yeah who wouldn't want to live there a
grand
where is east village american rent is
just
blowing my mind dude oh it's in london
what i take it back you want to live in
central london my dude oh it's not even
central
what the [ __ ] why why
why maybe it's not even london who
[ __ ] knows uh
do we have craigslist in uk oh we do all
right what are we going brian
where do you go to get like the
crackheads what the [ __ ]
oh what is craigslist what the hell
my meat and service charge what's the
service
is there any moderation on craigslist
what the hell is this
student punish after putting high school
up for sale on craigslist
well i wouldn't i'm not even surprised
anymore what the [ __ ] is this
ah that's just amazing that's a replica
right there a jalapeno
cheeto 350 i'll take him
i'm broke again what happened i bought i
i just saw this jalapenos cheeto i got
i had to have it i'm looking for people
who are interested in turning
100 to 4 000 it's not a pyramid scheme
uh what is it sunbae carrier the moon
wooden pool
i bought this and it didn't come with
water it cost more to fill than it costs
to buy
why do i doubt that what the [ __ ] minion
coffin i gotta have it
oh god that's dark i didn't realize what
it was oh no
i don't like this subreddit very much
i'm gonna be real with the guys
sleep under my brother's horse this is
all airbnb
house worth will keep you warm a bond
will reform
do not touch the horse maria
20 people review this oh god i'm soaked
20 bucks hot dog i mean it's kind of
cute
i lowkey want it a walmart pole 15 bucks
yes please how did you acquire this
walmart pole
oh i see you won it of course
you want to buy a used turkey made this
turkey last night
then thought about it didn't really want
to eat it 75 bucks
reasonable offer give it a just get it
do you want you want the turkey or not
75 bucks you want the [ __ ] turkey or
not wasp parts
50 per parts that's a steal
yeah i get some watch parts i was just
looking for that you can never find good
what what's part of the replacement for
my watch
yo playstation 5 prototype
quite large but great airflow five
thousand pounds i'll take it
can't stand her after covid my loss your
gain
well i guess that's another part of this
whole pandemic that we haven't
considered
if your relationship can make it through
a pandemic you can make it through
anything
someone got a goddamn mcdonald's
playground that's actually kind of cool
i wouldn't pay 5 000 for it though but
that's actually yeah
all right i can see what someone would
say not gonna lie if i had that kind of
money i'd be tempted yeah
i have that kind of money and i'm not
tempted it needs to be cheaper i would
offer like
200. you get it not even that yeesh
work it's great nice and heavy need to
sell fast
you want to buy a murder weapon for 20
bucks
okay
oh great i can buy a toyota supra oh
it's gta from gta 5 that's a steal
thank you i will fight any irish person
what the hell
162 centimeters
five four italian 27
jack are you up for the challenge
macbook pro
mine are blemishes you could barely
notice it
[ __ ] someone shot it did someone
actually buy the tiffany clip
what happened here oh god it's tiffany
again sterling silver tin can
tiffany get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ]
out tiffany
no one's gonna oh my god i'm done
done i'm done with this stop it this is
the most insane subreddit i have
reviewed in a long time and i've
reviewed a lot of subreddits if you
enjoyed
hit that like subscribe for more videos
and thank you for watching
uh we also have epic merch represent.com
pewdiepie thank you for checking out see
you guys
ah children of nine parks
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
you